what's up nick how's it going rich how
you doing man
well uh talking about your subject about
the in the beginning of the show that
i had this idea floating around i just
wanted to run it by you
that
uh
women
women have an innate fear
built into their system and that's how
media is corrupting them into
doing things that are
against their own best best interests
that you know like for example
the boss babe
they
they're overcompensating for
fear of looking weak or
women that are
you know
how do i see it
women that are uh
anxious they are fear of uh
you know making the wrong decision
and the media is using that to influence
them so i just wanted to run that by you
and see what you thought
yeah women are fear-based man they're
definitely like
as soon as the pandemic hit the first
people to start going all like scared
and you know masking up and
you know
was
beta men and feminize women you know
like that's that's how it rolls like
men lead and protect and women generally
follow so when they try to convince
women to be more like men they just end
up like awful versions of women and
that's how you get these boss [ __ ]
they're not well they're not really
bosses like no they're not they're not
going to beat me up they're all
overcompensating for looking weak
and there's nothing wrong with being the
weaker sex but it's the reason why they
call them the weaker sex they're the
ones that make the babies
exactly and
it's just i guess you can't be
vulnerable and strong at the same time
right it's like you know pick one right
exactly
okay well i just uh that's rolling
around inside my head so i just wanted
to see what
other people thought about it yeah no
problem all right nick thanks hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you